looking back on what you've applied to
the story with Emmet
what is something or some things that
you're almost embarrassed to admit that
weren't clear to you on actually writing
a script I know you said you you kind of
piece it together from different things
but what is something that you've liked
aha why did why didn't I think of that
earlier it was so clear
wow that's the story I mean first of all
I have ADHD so I have been clueless most
of my life I mean even even now I will
find out what I learned or what was
going on maybe a year from now I used to
be in the committee which was a very hip
you know like I was in second city that
was very hip you know far-reaching and
great satirical company but it took me
ten years to figure out wow we were so
cool I didn't think I was cool at all I
was just you know we were like training
Dobermans that's I mean we literally
said that out loud to ourselves we were
mr. Myerson mr. meat he was the director
and owner of the theater of the
committee and we were his trained
Dobermans he'd come in with a newspaper
and he said let's get Nixon you know and
I'd say well you know what and he'd say
well you know get up there and improvise
well you know we'll throw some stuff you
know blah blah blah and then he would we
would do that and he would come back
after you ended to show and he'd say
yeah explore that part about you know
what you were talking about there
explored that so he would and then so he
would just do what he said like trained
dogs now he wasn't writing the stuff
because we were in perhaps improvising
other states it was coming out of us and
he was kind of guiding it so in a way it
was our show but but I didn't know that
we really didn't know how intelligent we
were until we came off the stage after
making everybody laugh look took me ten
years to figure out how funny I was I
still find that to be true that in ten
years I'll find out how hip this here
thing is Wow was that cool so I'm always
in
time I I've given up trying to figure
out anything I just put one foot in
front of the other you know just you
just keep on going don't look back
you